اصطدام كارثي في ​​قلب
طوكيو تم التقاطه من
مقعد نافذة الراكب أروتو أما بينما اجتاحت النيران طائرته التابعة
للخطوط الجوية اليابانية
بصراحة، كنت خائفًا حتى الموت، كما
يقول عند الهبوط شعرت برعشة قوية
وعندما نظرت من النافذة رأيت
شرارات تطير الطائرة تحترق  عندما
توقفت الطائرة في أقل من دقيقة،
كانت المقصورة مليئة بالدخان، وتصاعد الدخان الأسود
عبر المقصورة في هذا الفيديو،
صوت
طفل صغير، يرجى تركنا نغادر بسرعة، وهو يقول
نداء مهذبًا لمساعدة المضيفات
المضطرات إلى استخدام مكبرات الصوت
الركاب المباشرون، تم كسر نظام الاتصالات على متن الطائرة قبل
ثوانٍ فقط من قطعها،
وأغلقت بعض مخارج الطوارئ الطاقم المكون من
12 فردًا، وتم إجلاء
367 شخصًا بنجاح، بما في ذلك ثمانية أطفال رضع،
ونجا الجميع بالكاد من كدمة.
التحقيق في
حادث تحطم الهيروين يوم الثلاثاء مع التركيز على أربع دقائق حاسمة من
5:43 إلى 5  :47 مساءاً  رحلة الخطوط الجوية اليابانية
JL 516 التي قامت بمقاربتها النهائية فوق
خليج طوكيو تم السماح لها بالهبوط في
مطار هانا تمامًا كما كانت المروحة التوربينية لخفر السواحل الياباني
تنسحب إلى المدرج C
مباشرةً في مسار
طائرة الإيرباص الأكبر حجمًا
35900 وهي تندفع على
المدرج مع ألسنة اللهب.  استهلك
الانفجار جسم الطائرة وابتلعت كرة نارية
كلا الطائرتين بالكامل في غضون
دقائق، مما
أتاح المواد المقاومة للحريق ومخارج الطوارئ للطائرة
وقتًا حيويًا لما يقرب من 400 شخص
للهروب من الجحيم، وتوفي ما لا يقل عن خمسة من
أفراد طاقم خفر السواحل،
وأصدرت وزارة النقل اليابانية
البيان الرسمي المكتوب  نص تلك
الدقائق الأربع الأخيرة التي تشير إلى احتمال حدوث
سوء فهم بين مراقبة الحركة الجوية وصوت قمرة القيادة
للطائرتين
يؤكد أن البرج يخبر
رحلة خفر السواحل بالتاكسي إلى
نقطة احتجاز، مما يعطي
تصريح الرحلة التجارية
للهبوط، النص والصوت يثير
أسئلة رئيسية لماذا كان  طائرة خفر السواحل
في المكان الخطأ لماذا
فشل طيارو الخطوط الجوية اليابانية في رؤية
الطائرة الأخرى وألغوا الهبوط
خاصة في أمسية صافية مع
رؤية جيدة، المعدن المشوه
والبلاستيك المنصهر هو تذكير بمدى سوء الأمر
وها هو الأمر  ما تبقى من
الطائرة لا يزال جالسًا على المدرج C هنا
في مطار هانا، هناك فريق من المحققين
بما في ذلك فنيون من
شركة إيرباص الذين يساعدون
المحققين اليابانيين في البحث عن
الصندوق الأسود المفقود والذي يمكن أن يوفر
أدلة مهمة في هذا الحادث الذي عطل
السفر بالنسبة للبعض.  20 ألف شخص
وأدى إلى مقتل خمسة أشخاص على الأقل ويل ريبلي
سي إن إن في مطار هانا بطوكيو